okay chair we're ready
thank you um welcome and good morning
everybody to this
meeting of the trafford cove with 19
public engagement board
for our first meeting of the municipal
year back after the elections
so welcome back to the council's as well
as everybody else
um attendances um i understand we have
no apologies today
uh unless anyone's gonna tell me
otherwise
uh item 2 on the agenda declarations of
interest
are there any decorations of interest to
be declared
thank you silence is golden on that so
the minutes of the last meeting which
were held on the 21st of april
uh 2021 can i take them as a red
and ask if there is a rising is it just
a correction
yes the minutes uh say the date was
nine it should be the 21st the minutes
say
19th they do actually absolutely right
uh so fabiola will you pick that up
point please
uh sure wheelchair thank you thank you
very much thanks carl for bringing us
that to my attention um
if there are no matters arising we'll
press on then to the
current update on the kobe 90 situation
trafford from uh director of public
health eleanor rove eleanor thank you
thank you councillor freeman um so over
the
last couple of weeks we've started
seeing our cases rise a little bit again
um and obviously we're particularly
concerned um
to make sure that we are absolutely on
top of the cases
given what's happened in bolton so what
we're doing is
that we we are now being all um
all um pcr tests that are undertaken in
greater manchester are now being sent
for genomic sequencing
so we're able to find out whether we
have any of the variants of concern in
the borough
the um difficulty with the genomic
sequencing is it takes 10 days
to two weeks to undertake so by the time
you find out that somebody has a
variance of concern
actually their self-isolation period has
finished
so what we're doing is making sure that
we um are
undertaking enhanced contact tracing for
all of our cases that we see
so that we can absolutely get on top of
them and make sure that we're doing that
tracing of any further contacts
encouraging people to uh
self-isolate and making sure that we
we stop that chain of transmission in
that way because what we don't want to
do
is find two weeks later that we had a
variant of concern that we hadn't
responded to appropriately
so um i think my plea for for the public
is um you know we have seen rates come
down in
in trafford it's it and and our rates do
remain relatively low
we're below 50 per hundred thousand at
the moment which is good news
um we're still above the england average
we're seeing fewer cases in older people
and we are seeing more cases in younger
people in our school age population
and we know that without taking
steps to address it we would see that
spread going into
into older populations a vaccination
uptake has been great
um but we still have some pockets where
we when
only it's about 70 percent vaccinated
which is really good
you know the 7 out of 10 even in is
fantastic but we do need to increase
those vaccination rates particularly
we're seeing lower uptake in the north
of the borough and there's a lot of work
going on in that area
and in particular we've done really well
with reaching some of our asian
population
in that area and that we now see
higher vaccination uptake in some of our
ethnic minority groups
than in the white population but it is
really making sure that we do get that
vaccination rate as high as we possibly
can
as quickly as we can and making sure
that people go for that second dose
because it's absolutely critical that
second dose
to give people that extra bit of
protection and also to make sure
that we think that that second dose is
also really important to stop
transmission
so it's a really important one for
protecting yourself and protecting
others
with the lateral flow tests a lot of
people are doing lateral flow tests very
regularly obviously particularly
anybody linked to school or people going
into work we'd encourage people to
continue to do that
but if you have any symptoms please
don't use the lateral flow test go
straight for a pcr
the advantage of doing the pcr is it's
more accurate
with the lateral flow we could miss a
positive case
so do go for the lateral flow don't do
it do do go for the pcr
don't do a lateral flow and think if
you've got any symptoms because you
might get a false negative
go for the pcr and the other benefit of
that pcr
is that we will then be able to do that
that genomic sequencing will be done
so we'll be able to get on top of any
variants of concern very quickly
if we know where they are um
the other thing is that we know and i've
seen this repeatedly in trafford and it
is absolute testament to the
to our fantastic population we know that
most people's contact tracing they do
really effective contact tracing
themselves
so if you do get a positive test or if
you have symptoms do tell your friends
and family that you've been
in contact with please tell them
straight away so they can still
start self-isolating because if they
know straight away
that again is really important in
breaking that chain of transmission
if you can tell your friends and family
you'll do it much more quickly than we
can get reach you
or nhs test and trace can reach people
so it's that
please please do continue to do that and
i we know we've seen this in many
many of the outbreaks that we've seen in
trafford that actually people
have um have already have clearly been
in touch with friends and family
and people have gone for testing and
that's been one of the ways we've
managed to limit some of the spread
in the borough so i think um i think
those were my main
my main messages um because at the
moment it feels in trafford that
um you know if if we all do all the
things we can
everybody i know everybody's delighted
about hospitality reopening
we all want to keep that open so please
do just just try and be that extra bit
careful
don't go into play if the place seems
noisy or crowded please don't go in it
stay outside where you can and um
think about think about this the the
fact that you might be being exposed or
you might expose other people
and protect yourselves protect others
and take up that vaccination
thank you elena before i look for
questions is there any messages you want
to to give out about the wearing of
masks
in schools um just bearing in mind that
i know that bolton have certainly asked
for them to be continued i know we have
put some guidance
out what we're saying in the schools
is um because it's a it's a really
tricky one
and um my view is at the moment
maintaining education for children is
the most important thing
wearing face mask gives some protection
but it's not a total solution and i
think
i'm i'm happy at the moment for this to
be guided by the head teachers within
the schools
if we have an outbreak in the school i
would definitely be
recommending that the head teacher um
asks that
pupils wear head face coverings again
but for some of our pupils i think
people have found it very difficult
wearing the face coverings
sometimes and people have found
sometimes that it has impeded
their education and communications so i
think it's
i would like people to if if children
want to wear face coverings i think that
is absolutely fine and they should be
allowed to
if they don't want to i wouldn't want to
see anyone excluded from school at the
moment on that basis so i think it is
for the schools to
um the schools you know we will work
with the individual schools
if we feel there's a significant risk in
the schools we will absolutely in a
particular school
at the moment with the rates as they are
in trafford the guidance is that
children don't need to wear face
coverings and that's the national
guidance
um we would support a school in um
particularly if there was an outbreak we
would absolutely
want the school to reintroduce face
coverings but at the moment
i think um we can leave it to the head
teacher's discretion
thank you elena um and whilst you just
before we do move to questions are there
any
messages you think we need to reinforce
with with the
residents and our public around things
like washing hands sanitizing keeping
that going at all
i think it's it's just those general
messages that we
you know we we're seeing our cases rise
slightly
um and it's it goes
it can go very quickly it is in our
younger population and we know they're
the people you know they they're very
active they go around
and and that's great and we do want to
see our young people able to socialize
and so on more but it is that
that point that actually there is
infection out there and we need to be
very very cautious so i would absolutely
say
stay outside where you can limit the
number of people you see
do go for that vaccination as soon as
you're eligible for it
do take that second dose because that's
absolutely critical
and um yeah we're not out of the woods
which is i know and and our numbers are
as i say
increasing slightly very fortunately not
increasing greatly in our older
population we have very few cases in our
older population
about a third of our cases are in people
under 18 at the moment
but we know that we can't we you know
the
the way i've covered the way of any
infectious disease it doesn't stay in in
one population so we just need to keep
on
i think keep being careful
thank you um i'm going to vote for
questions and i know that khan has got a
question he wants to ask them
accounts the new question anyone else
wants to raise their hand i'll pick them
up from there thank you
can't yeah thank you chair
um it's not a question i think it's
worth mentioning now
that the effort which has been put in by
many leaders in the communities is
paying off
and the word of mouth is much more
important than actually giving speeches
um and we find that more and more people
are now beginning to take the tests as
eleanor just said that the take-up is
is better uh than before and
i think we just need to pay tribute to
people who put their time and energy
into uh putting their head above the
parapet and actually talking about this
issue
and asking people to go and get tested
and even now
we are actually getting many people who
are asking where can they go to get a
test or to get
a vaccination and of course wherever
their vaccination centers are open
we are directing people towards those
thank you
absolutely echo that the work that the
voluntary and community sector have done
has been absolutely outstanding in this
i
really yeah absolutely echo everything
we wouldn't have made
any of the progress we've made without
those those
um trusted local voices and that that
messaging
um just and um you know and the mosques
the way
in particular i want to thank the
mosques for the work that they've done
um and we had a really successful um eid
prayers
this year um in north trafford um
absolutely phenomenally well managed
really well supported as well by the
police
and by the council but i'm led by
obviously lead and are organized
um and so well organized by the mosque
leaders and i know that they
they are absolutely giving the messages
about testing about um symptom
awareness and about the importance of
vaccination and we really do value it
thank you elena thank you khan
councillor new gross
oh thank you and thank you elena for
that great report there
i just wanted to bring up on that second
dose vaccination you mentioned
i do recall last week as part of the
bolton
um numbers there was a message that over
50s would to have their second dose
brought
forward are we in place are we capable
to to deal with that and
please chat along to another person if
it isn't quite cool yes so
um i'm sure um have we got our
commitment to
rebecca we are and rebecca will tell you
how
thank you probably that will be that was
the main item for my vaccination update
so
um you're absolutely right councillor um
the guidance that has been um now
published on the recommendation of the
um
joint committee is um to bring forward
the second dose um
schedule from week 12 to um
week eight um as a maximum so
um in order to kind of answer your
question on that absolutely we are
accelerating our coverage 19 vaccination
program
um and through the primary care networks
we are now inviting anyone who has
received their first dose more than 28
days ago
to book in for a second dose which will
take place then at least
eight weeks after the first dose and to
support that
the um the primary care networks are
following up all of those patients who
would do their second dose to um
reinforce that message and there's some
national comes um available as well
and the national booking line has also
um scheduled in some additional
appointment capacity so
patients who had their first dose
through a mass vaccination site or a
pharmacy
are also able to access those
appointments earlier too
and the delivery schedule for the
vaccination program has been
adapted obviously to meet that increased
um
activity over the coming weeks and that
is both
fires and astrazeneca obviously with the
guidance that's come out around
the astrozenic vaccine so we're now
we're now getting um
adequate provision of both types of
vaccine so i hope that answers your
question
thank you very much uh thank you rebecca
and thank you
any further questions at all for elena i
i don't see any um so we will move on
therefore to
mass testing and i'll before i bring
donner in donna i believe it's your last
day with us today
so can i just uh pass on the thanks of
of
uh my thanks and the thanks of us all
for all the work you've done over the
years for traffic and particularly the
work that you've done
in the last eight 15 16 months on this
uh on on the pandemic um it's been
invaluable you've always given us very
very
concise and good updates and kind of
wish you all the best
in uh for pastors new over to you donna
oh thank you chair that was a very very
kind uh
comment um i live in trafford chair so
i'll be i'll be around and still doing
things
uh as the word progresses uh and
we'll be very encouraged about that um
just a very brief update
in terms of testing so our position is
very stable at the moment chair
both in terms of provision and in terms
of access the community collect model
means now that alongside that and the
national distribution most people have
relatively easy access to lateral flow
testing
and as eleanor says we're encouraging
people to use that as part of their
return to normal activities so that's
really good news
we have had acknowledgement from
national organizations that the
community collect model
will continue for at least another nine
months so we can see testing as being
part of that
triage in terms of vaccination testing
and um
the copied safe behaviors as being
really key parts
um our mtus are still operating
we will do a review just to make sure
that we've got um the appropriate staff
at the appropriate sites and we're just
drafting our plan which i'm sure
eleanor will alert you to later in terms
of any responses to
um vaccines of concern because sometimes
chair we might have to
um expedite a small team to go in a
certain geographical area
or to a certain setting so we're all on
top of that
and hopefully and we'll be ready when
that if and when that need arises
thank you chair
thank you don are there questions for
donald at all
i don't see any thanks very much donna
and all the best
going forward um we'll move then on to
contact tracing and outbreak management
and i've got helen collins and
kate murdock helen
i have a feeling helen's had to dash out
she's um kate's on leave this week and
um
helen's covering the inbox which is uh
busier than it has been but um at the
moment um
as i said at the start we've been doing
um
a lot of enhanced contact tracing with
all of our cases so that we really
understand everything that's going on
with each of those cases and get a
really good feel
for that we we definitely find that
doing it locally
bears fruit because um the national you
know it's just the conversations that
people can have if you know the area
um it just makes a difference to people
so um my main message is to everybody
please be as honest and open as you can
with the contact tracers it is really
important that we understand where
people have been what they've been doing
it's um it's not about judging anyone
you know there's asymptomatic
transmission we know nobody's
deliberately going out
and trying to catch covet it does happen
um
so please please do be honest because
this is one of the ways and and
share them all of the contacts you think
you might have had
you know we can then have a conversation
with you about whether the person
is a contact whether they would need to
self-isolate all of that you know you
can have that conversation with us
um but it is really important that we do
track down everybody's contacts so that
we can
we can understand any spread and um and
get on top of it
because you can't vaccinate yourself out
of pandemic
it's a really really helpful tool it's
fantastic that we have the vaccination
and it is absolutely the thing that's
making the difference between um the
health service being able to cope and
not able to cope
but as well as the vaccination we need
to be able to
identify people quickly so that's that
testing
that contact tracing so that we break
the chain of transmission and stop any
further spread and stop the illness
so in order to in order to keep places
open um
and i think our main goal at the moment
is really trying to make sure that we
keep places open
we're working really closely as well
with all of our workplaces
um to make sure that they um are
absolutely up to date with the guidance
on how to be covert secure
we've got a few a few active outbreaks
at the moment
um including a few cases in schools but
again um you know our schools have been
absolutely phenomenal
throughout the heads have been
absolutely amazing and the teachers and
and indeed the children and families so
um we are we are working to make sure
that those cases
we're not seeing lots of spread within
schools um and similarly with other
workplaces so
the main message is if you if you if if
in doubt
get in touch with us we're always happy
to talk to people
get in touch with us with the first case
and we we can talk to you
and try and give you support well
just just while we're on can i just also
make mention of the work that's
obviously been done
uh with manchester united to me to allow
us to get
10 000 fans in there last night yeah
i've no doubt we'll be watching
anxiously now to see
if if there's any uh um uh
any issues arising out of that but of
course it's part and parcel of
the return to our near normal i just
think of you would you like to comment
on some of that work that's been
being done because yeah again um big
piece of work with um
with obviously united to making massive
efforts to
to bring back fans and i think people
are absolutely delighted to be back
um and also obviously our environmental
health team who've worked incredibly
hard
on supporting united to make everything
covet secure helen was at the match last
night
um with nicola i don't know if nicholas
on the call from
environmental health but um you know
again it's a massive operation trying to
make all of this
secure the obviously the outdoor bits of
the match
are it's the getting two and the getting
around the stadium that
that causes the worry but um again
united have worked very very hard
and i know our environmental health team
have worked very hard in supporting them
to make this safe
and um obviously in the next thing we've
got another game haven't they and then
the
trip to gadansk which is
exercising minds at the moment
thank you uh i did think it was worth
dimensions i do know that the efforts
that
have gone in by all our staff um and and
you know and without
let's be absolutely clear without the
efforts of the council staff
in such circumstances these events
wouldn't be going ahead
absolutely and i think you know our
environmental health team have been
just phenomenal of what they've had to
do and the work they've done throughout
the pandemic has been
absolutely amazing the support they've
given to businesses
the the advice and guidance that they
give is absolutely second to none they
are excellent
and that is borne out by the feedback
that i think i certainly i've received
and i know
fellow counselors have received so so a
big thanks to them
um are there any questions on um on on
contact tracing outbreak management at
all from anybody
don't see any shall we move on to
rebecca uh
uh demanding for mass vaccination you
may have covered this rebecca already
but
over to you um thank you yeah i've
covered the main item which was just the
update
on the um bring forward of the second
doses i just want to as well from my
perspective echo the
um comments made earlier about the
invaluable
um contribution from the community and
obviously i'm responsible for primary
care and
the the networks have done a great job
in terms of our numbers but
we wouldn't have been anywhere near
where we are without the support that
we've got from the
volunteers and community so thanks from
um me also
we are seeing increased uptake um
which is a result of the work the
community engagement team have done and
the people we've talked about but i also
think the recent news and what's
happening in bolton is helping
uh you know we don't want to make that a
positive thing i think
we are seeing um a greater request now
for second doses which is good
um so that probably covers most of my
update really just in terms of numbers
um as of the 12th of may the running
total of first dose vaccines delivered
across trafford was 121
249 and the running total of second dose
vaccines um on the same day it was 65
and 1868 so
um phenomenal efforts by all so that
that probably concludes my update
any questions thank you chair
thank you rebecca as one of the sixty
five thousand eight hundred and sixty
eight and so i'm quite delighted
um um any questions for rebecca at all
from anybody
i think just just one thing i forgot to
mention and you've again seen it in the
news that the
um the your covered vaccination status
is now available through the nhs
app and so the nhs app which is
different to the nhs code
19 app it's the it's the broader one um
does now have
the ability to provide you with your
status and can be shared for purposes of
travel or whatever and whatever is
needed and so that's just um helpful to
know
if you've not got the app if people are
digitally enabled that can also be
confirmed by
your gp that is useful information
because i wasn't aware of that so
thank you very much rebecca okay make
sure you're gone
well we'll do um so moving on then
bringing nigel smith on community
engagement nigel
good morning everybody so uh in terms of
an update from the community engagement
team the
uh one of the key things i just wanted
to mention again was the community
champions program
so um we are due to launch this
imminently we've got a press release and
associated social media due to be issued
later this week
so just to remind everyone of the
approach we're taking we're going to
invite people in the community to be
community champions who can share
covert 19 advice and other essential
messaging and information
with their own community contacts and
networks including on the vaccinations
testing self-isolation support and
advice things like that so
what we want to do is um provide the
opportunity for the champions to share
their insights as well uh with us
and get feedback from the community so
um that's the approach we're taking
we've developed a website where the
champions can sign up and they'll get a
welcome pack there'll be a welcome video
from eleanor
and there's going to be the fortnightly
check-ins with uh
colleagues from the public health team
and also with the community engagement
team
so we're looking to um
the real big ask really is just for
people to look out for the press release
on social media it's going to be coming
out later this week and just really
encourage
people are interested to sign up or at
least look at the website to find out
more
next i just wanted to mention around
some of the engagement exercises and
activities we've been undertaking
so um last month we undertake a very
very focused
um door knocking exercise in the north
of the borough
to talk to people about how they're
feeling and concerns they had as things
were starting to open up at that time it
was a very focused exercise
and as much as anything what we wanted
to do was just pilot and test our
approach
so we've undertaken an evaluation
exercise kind of debrief on how that
went and there was lots of learning for
us as a team
in terms of what worked well what didn't
in terms of the methodology and approach
so
at the moment we're just refining that
model so that we've got something there
ready to use
for a future engagement activity that we
want to do another thing that we're
doing
this week actually is we're undertaking
a community listening exercise
in old trafford outside one of the
primary schools in old trafford where
we're talking to parents and guardians
at
school pick up and drop off time so that
again is going to give us some really
valuable
insight in terms of um you know where
people are in terms of vaccinations
testing support for self-isolation and
just about
you know the impact of covered really
and how people are feeling so
the first day was yesterday went really
well and the team spoke to around 100
parents so um by the end of the week we
should have some really really good
insight
from that activity um i just wanted to
just mention voice of bme again
as we mentioned previously they they
continue to make a real difference
through the work they're doing with the
practices in the north
uh and they're talking to people who
were initially hesitant about taking the
vaccine
giving them facts and reassurance asking
i think it'd be better to support it
and then booking them a vaccination if
they want to go ahead with one and
today i think the latest information i
have is that 79 people
change their minds have now decided to
be vaccinated so just a real good
achievement there from voice of bme and
we are currently having conversations
with them around
um working in the partington area to
help increase uh vaccine uptake there as
well so we've got our meeting with them
next week to look at that
and uh in terms of further activities as
has already been mentioned we've had
some real
success in terms of increase in the
vaccination uptake with the asian
communities
and so our focus is uh obviously to
continue with that work
also to focus on communities where
there's still lower uptake so
we are looking at first some things
we've been doing is in terms of uh
cross-boundary promotion of clinics
uh where they're aimed at specific
communities so some of these are held
over the border in hume or wally range
but we're promoting those clinics
we are working with the um khan which is
the caribbean and african health network
and we're looking to help do some
further work with them because they've
got a real presence and reach
into in the black british communities in
old trafford
we're also looking next week to do
some further work with the polish
communities in old trafford
uh to build up a bit of an engagement
approach there so that's something that
we're looking to do next week
and um we've also been doing some
outreach with homeless people
uh throughout trafford for example at
white city to understand
you know if they've been vaccinated what
issues there might be if they've
not been vaccinated and what kind of
best offer would there would be to
support them from a logistical point of
view
so that's mainly it from my point of
view uh the one i think sorry just to
mention was this um
we're looking to develop a do your bit
campaign in the north of trafford as
well
and we're just at the moment uh just
getting details of around four or five
people who
are who have been vaccinated who are
positive examples of local people which
we can then
promote widely again to just uh promote
vaccine takeoff
so that was it in terms of an update for
me check thank you
nigel i have any questions for nigel
from anyone at all
i don't see any nigel um
so we will move on to uh community
enforcement
uh helen grant helen hi
how are you um
okay so the weekly enforcement meeting
is
still occurring so we're working in
partnership with the
police and housing and with other
departments across the
authority and from a residential
complaints point of view then i was
where was chicken's teeth so you'll
remember at the height of the pandemic
we were getting 60 70 80
complaints a week about you know
households mixing and so on and so forth
the guidance is now that six people or
two households can meet
indoors and up to 30 people outdoors and
and it seems in the main that there is
compliance around that but we're
certainly not
seeing anything like the levels of
complaints that that we were during the
height of the pandemic
and we've obviously been working in
partnership to support the
safe reopening um of both kind of retail
and hospitality and so this week
indoor hospitality has reopened
in the main it's been really good
compliance around that
environmental health have worked really
hard in terms of giving advice or where
there have been
slight breaches going and speaking to
those specific businesses
and obviously licensing have also worked
really hard in terms of
giving out pavement licenses and the
like to support those businesses i was
in altringham yesterday
actually in the town centre and it just
looked really really good obviously the
sun was shining and
people were sat outside and enjoying
shopping and really good compliance
helena touched on there is a separate
group that deals with
um kind of security advisory group
measures so for the larger kind of
sporting events like elena touched on
man united and things like the cricket
and so do they deal with that in a
separate
meeting and what we're seeing now is
probably the more
business as usual type kind of seasonal
anti-social behavior type complaints so
not
really covered related and kind of
mindful that young people have perhaps
been a bit
cooped up over the last 12 months or so
and
so just you know and ask to parents to
please ask your
children or young people if they're out
you know we want them to be
enjoying themselves but please be
responsible and be mindful of causing
nuisance to neighbours particularly in
kind of public spaces
we did discuss the weekly enforcement
group
reducing the frequency of that meeting
and going to a fortnightly meeting
we've held off that just for the moment
and obviously with indoor hospitality
reopening
this week and being mindful of what's
happening in bolton
we just want to keep a bit of an eye on
things over the next couple of weeks so
we will
reassess that after the bank holiday and
see where we are
there that's the update from me and kind
of where we are at the moment but
um certainly a lot better than it it
could have been
perhaps some of my fears but it's nice
to see people kind of back
we just need the summer to come now and
this rain to go away
uh thank you helen and can i just uh say
i think that's a very sensible approach
to take
keeping to weekly meetings and reviewing
it in maybe two or three weeks time
once we've got past the bank holiday um
because um
i suppose the concern is is that you
know
that we there's still a need for people
to be cautious
and i just really um repeat what eleanor
said at the start
i actually went to sale makers market on
sunday
and i came away after 10 minutes because
it was just so
so busy and and it's about people making
that choice
i think and and and applying common
sense
but so thank you any questions at all
for
um helen at all
uh councillor welter
hello there hi helen um yeah
thank you very much for for that update
i think uh you know
you're right it suddenly is great to see
altringham
buzzing again um i think the you know
the only concern in altering him is you
know is what happens
later on in the evening you know maybe
as more
drink has been consumed and uh maybe
inhibitions are loosened
a bit and i'm just wondering what you
know is it what
extra provision we can provide at uh you
know at those kind of sensitive times of
night
um you know as you say people have got a
lot of
pent-up energy to uh you know to release
and uh there's just uh
i know that there have been some reports
of some incidents around
um you know the the what is it the one
all triumph
area in the lower market um and
you could imagine similar in goose green
and that kind of thing later on in the
day
so we did put some additional staffing
in
around the initial reopening so we used
an external
and security company along with our own
staff and with environmental health
and licensing we have put the
onus onto the licensed premises
and to have their own security who
should be
managing that and then if there is a
specific issue then environmental health
will go and deal with that in terms of
the
the premises owner and it was quite
expensive to prefer to put the
um additional security on for those
couple of weekends
and just you know we wanted to kind of
see how it how it went and there would
be an initial
kind of rush of people wanting to go out
but certainly we have put the
onus on to the um business owners but
what we've said is if there are
issues with those specific premises and
then we will pick those up with those
individual premises
and the police are out and about as well
so obviously they work
shifts more than we do but they keep an
eye on things as well
yeah thank you i mean certainly the
owners should be on the businesses
themselves to
you know to get there cleo entailed to
behave in the in the manner that's
expected so
that's good i think you know we okay
what eleanor said as well about people
being responsible and taking some
personal responsible notwithstanding
that people forget that one
and they've had a few sheriffs but you
know would kind of like stress that to
people that
you know this reopening is because we
are where we are and we don't want to
to go back and so let's kind of move
forward and do it safely together
yeah thank you very much uh thank you
council welton and and yes uh i i'd
probably endorse what you're saying
there helen
about the illness being on businesses
and licensees
to to be responsible i think that was
reported yesterday
a big incident in in northern moore just
across our border
which was in the evening news uh uh but
and that resulted from a pub being open
all day so
it's it's you know it's about people um
businesses being responsible and also
people taking responsibility as well
um is there um any other can i just
i was just going to add to that and it
is that um you know i think when the
when
we've all been desperate for the
hospitality to reopen
and we want us it to stay open
and that does mean we all we can't go
back to the behaviors
we had 18 months ago we have to think
differently
and and part of that is actually about
thinking about how we limit our contacts
and actually
only going out when we have to now if
you want to go to the pub
or a restaurant you have to go out to
them but actually we should still be
working from home if we can and i would
really strongly encourage people
if you can work from home continue to
work from home
don't go rushing back into the workplace
because it's the more contacts we have
in the more different places
so think about what you can do for it
safely from home and
um and then think about if you know
because that will be the
really key to keeping hospitality open
is
um is keeping keeping our other contacts
lower um so that's again and as helen
says it is about
it is about we we need to take personal
responsibility
um and but we also need people to have a
bit of fun finally
so it's it's getting that balance thank
you eleanor
is there um any other business at all
i don't see any i'm going to end with
the cheery note that
since we've been on the meeting matt
hancock's called a 5 p.m downing street
conference
on the indian variant tonight
which has now been identified in 40 of
local authority areas
so it isn't over and and
the message has to be that people have
got to still
continue to exercise caution going
forward
on that basis then if there's no further
business i will
we'll call the meeting there to a close
can i thank you all for your attendances
and we'll see you all again in a
fortnight's time
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much bye-bye
bye-bye oh thank you before we go just
one thing
can i just thank george devlin i should
have done it at the start
who the the last meeting on the uh
on the 21st of april thank you george uh
much appreciated
in the absence of councillors at that
meeting thank you